see like we are then going I certainly
do because it makes me realize how lucky
I am
Jackie Bali was settling well into her
care home she had lived a full life but
dementia had taken over on April as 16
Jackie died from coronavirus her family
couldn't get there in time to say
goodbye like so many families affected
by this disease I'm lucky that she's got
carers with her who had known it for a
long time so I knew that they were with
her but you feel terrible that you're
not able to be there and then on the
other hand you all you also have to
think about the fact that if you were
attending would you put yourself and
your family at risk by going so it's
it's a know a situation and it's a
horrible situation to be in Jackie's
death and thousands of others reveal how
devastating kovat 19 has been in care
homes where the most vulnerable in
society live knowing this risk in March
the government reissued guidance to
social care explaining that the NHS will
seek to discharge more patients into
care homes and that care homes need to
be prepared at the same time the NHS was
writing to care homes asking them to set
aside as many beds as possible so that
the elderly could be transferred from
wards back into care homes but we've
been told of cases where patients were
discharged before they were well enough
and without getting a test potentially
putting thousands of residents at risk
of contracting the virus a Liao Mufti
owns a residential home in Wales one of
his residence was discharged after being
on the same Ward as suspected covered 19
cases the ladies patient notes reveal
why she was sent home the ward had
possible cases and that discharge had
been taken off nurses as there is a
drive to clear the hospital and beds do
you think that eagerness to clear beds
put residents under the residence in
those homes at risk
social care providers say that if they
had better protective clothing and tests
throughout this crisis deaths could have
been prevented
I wonder if you will take this
opportunity to apologize to those
families of loved ones who died in care
homes because the government didn't
properly protect them that's the thing
is Nick I think that's I think that's
unreasonable as a question actually and
and I know you care an awful lot about
this but from the start we know we knew
that there was a very significant
challenge with care homes not least
because of the frailty of the of the
residents it has been more difficult to
get data flowing and I'm very glad we're
able to do that now on a daily basis
instead of a weekly basis as before and
and making sure that care homes have the
support they need has been absolutely at
front of mind right from the start why
did it take you so long to give the
sector what it was crying out for and
that was tests well we have been testing
in care homes right from the start and
throughout the crisis so that's one of
the things in your question that I
dispute and I know the passion that you
have for this subject but it is really
important to base to attend to and to
express to explain what's been going on
and we've been testing right from the
start there was a crisis in our care
homes before the pandemic coronavirus
has exposed even more weaknesses in a
system that is crying out for reform
McMartin Sky News